from the superhuman to the supernatural
from dystopian futures to Disney
features shows it was a very big year
for action-packed effects-heavy movies
because the race for the oscars heats up
here's one thing we know 27 of the last
30 movies to win best visual effects
have something in common
what is it the surprising answer lies at
Pixar to infinity and beyond
yes that Pixar meat render man an
incredibly powerful software engine that
goes well beyond animation up until that
point the look the lighting essentially
had to be done by programmers ed catmull
is a co-founder of Pixar but he started
his career at Industrial Light and Magic
George Lucas's famous effects studio I
owe em had been trying to find ways to
blend live-action sequences with visual
effects and Catmull led the computer
graphics team which set in motion the
innovations that would become render man
back then you actually had to write code
to generate effects so the animations in
1982 Tron just for one example had to be
produced a frame at a time an incredible
amount of
instead of processing an image pixel by
pixel il M's technology made it possible
to render a line at a time and turned a
task that used to take days into a
matter of hours and render man dressed
that code level magic up in a graphical
interface with things like menus and
clickable buttons not unlike the way
windows demystified personal computing
by offering an alternative to the
command line the resulting software
allowed artists to realize their
creative visions without an extra level
of insane technical know-how the key to
figuring this all out was something
called the Rays algorithm what rays
stands for it renders everything you
ever saw and we took that pretty
seriously it's a very powerful and very
flexible extensible rendering platform
and boy did we use it
ILM launched Ray's in 1982 s Star Trek
to the Wrath of Khan computer request
security procedure well our initial
efforts were to convince people of its
value and it worked
eylem built the simulation of a planet
being terraformed all those effects
flying through digital landscapes
watching the oceans overtake mountains
would have been unthinkable with older
methods there were a lot of things that
were striking about that the particle
effects from the impact it was fire that
spreads around the planet and then as
the surface is growing up
those are fractal terrains that are kind
of building up incrementally as the shot
continues with the power of its rays
architecture ILM also introduced digital
motion blur an effect that's used all
the time now to simulate how ric fast
motion
in this aerial combat sequence from
Return of the Jedi just a year later you
can see that the motion blur not only
conveys a sense of speed but also helps
blend the miniatures into the frame in
1985 they made another big leap forward
with the introduction of the stained
glass knight a character that jumped off
a window and into real life in the movie
young Sherlock Holmes I still love the
close-up of the of the Knights hands
holding the sword because there's a rack
focus in that that's the focal effect
you see there where the focus shifts
from the Knights hands to his face and
that's was rendered into it so that's
you know one of those amazing
capabilities that Renderman had from the
very beginning and they used the same
tools a few years later to make this in
James Cameron's movie The Abyss it was
just this one little scene but that one
scene of the pseudopod pushed the very
notion of what digital artists could do
by allowing them to give an artificial
object virtually any characteristic
Baker dream of and they took it even
further in James cameras next movie
Terminator 2
he decided he would like computer
graphics help make a main character in
Terminator 2 which was that liquid man
you know the revolutionary thing that we
did on t2 with being able to take
live-action plates and project them onto
computer graphics and then distort them
being able to do that kind of thing in
this engine was very enabling for us and
then in 1993 Jurassic Park came out
you know the original plan on Jurassic
Park was that was going to be
articulated stop-motion puppets all of
that talk went away as soon as we saw
that the first test of rendered
computer-generated dinosaur and because
render man supported motion blur and
right out of the box you could get that
very fluid and realistic motion that
just you know wow it everyone
and once effects artists started getting
comfortable with animals and creatures
they started experimenting with humanoid
creatures like Gollum from Lord of the
Rings
[Music]
it was so stunning here was this strange
creature and he absolutely was real when
I saw that was sort of translucent skin
if like oh that's awesome that
translucent skin that made Gollum look
so alive when he emerged from the
shadows in 2002's the two towers
utilized a brand new technique something
known as subsurface scattering
subsurface scattering is a phenomenon
that you see and materials that are
partially translucent you know it has a
solid surface but light enters that to
that surface travels some way down into
the surface and you know bounces around
and and sort of scatters through the
surface without subsurface scattering
skin looks opaque and inanimate
simulating what light does below the
skin gives it depth and softens the
texture making everything just a little
bit more well human this effect soon
became crucial to making CG objects feel
natural Noel's team used it again to
create Davy Jones in the Pirates of the
Caribbean series
Davy Jones was making kind of extreme
use of subsurface scattering he looks a
little bit like a jellybean because of
that but I was really very pleased with
the look and it's it's the kind of thing
that you couldn't have done as a make-up
appliance because the the scattering is
so deep movie after movie drew on the
power of render man to realize their
ambitions the x-men films 300 hyoeun man
and the birth of the MCU Pixar movies
but we'll get back to them in a second
these guys are professionals they're the
best and when the Star Wars saga
lucasfilm's crown jewel made a comeback
in the 2010s you can probably guess what
software artists used to recapture the
practical effect glory of the original
trilogy doesn't sound so bad to me so in
rogue one like all the travel of
spacecraft and you know this base battle
is computer graphics but we were very
deliberately trying to evoke the
aesthetics of the original miniatures
one way they did that using something
called path tracing which simulates how
light bounces off objects it's what
makes the space sequences more realistic
than you might have even registered
here's how a laser looked in Return of
the Jedi painted onto the frame but with
path tracing calculating the way the
light bounces the same laser in rogue
one casts an ambient glow onto the
x-wing fighter and here path tracing
doesn't just account for the shadows of
the smaller ships appearing on the
larger one below but it captures the
light bouncing off of the larger ship
and illuminating the underside of the
ships above you might not notice these
things in the moment but that's the
whole point the light is part of the
reality of the frame
not an after effect and when they wrote
grand moff tarkin into the movie rather
than recasting the late peter cushing
render man made it happen using the same
subsurface scattering technique they'd
used with golem and Davy Jones when has
become now while IOM and other VFX
houses have been using CG to enhance
live-action Pixar has been using render
man to build its own wondrous animated
world's started with their very first
film Toy Story and it was magic it was
like it was like there was magic and
alchemy happening at night overnight on
the render farm creating these images
Lee Unkrich was an editor on Toy Story
Toy Story came out in 1995 by then
render man had already been used to make
the pseudopod and the t1000 but all
digital animation needs to be rendered
whether it's for a five-second explosion
for a full-length scene and that's why
renderman changed the rules for animated
films a full-length movie is a massive
amount of information all of which needs
to get rendered out
[Music]
on the original toy story there was a
reason that we made a movie about toys
because back then those were easier
images to create things that were made
out of wood plastic glass reflective
kind of simple textures we knew how to
do really well what was harder were kind
of more organic forms like grass and
trees everything was always in the
service of the stories that we were
trying to create it was never about oh
let's let's make it do this cool new
thing it was never that it was instead
we've got a movie with monsters and we
want some of the monsters to be covered
with fur and we've never done fur before
so how are we gonna figure out how to do
that in a way that's direct a bowl and
art-director bowl so that we have
control over it you can create exactly
what we want and then that was the case
as well on Finding Nemo with the water
like everything underwater and the look
of the water these were all things that
we hadn't tackled before and not many
people had and so it was it was fun to
be ground breaking through the years but
at the same time is always in the
service of trying to make great movies
tell great stories a history of Pixar is
a history of watershed moments but of
course everyone has their favorite
is there one moment that stands out to
you as something that maybe surprised
you or or moved you the one that
actually leaps out at me was we took a
very major jump from our first film Toy
Story 1 you know you're in rooms and
you've got the characters made out of
plastic don't let it get to you woody Oh
what I don't what do you mean and then
the next one was to go to organic forms
and still holds up very beautiful and
then the next one was with ratatouille
there was a I think it's sensitivity to
that not everyone can become a great
artist but a great artist can come from
anywhere and a beauty that is just
astounded me at the time I will be
returning to gusto soon well just about
every Pixar film used renderman to
pioneer new techniques and technologies
all of that culminated in the studio's
most complex movie to date 2017 s Coco
it's not just in me it is there were
very few things that we hadn't done
before it was more a matter of scale
like we were doing things at a scale
that we had never done before take the
moment when Miguel crosses the Marigold
bridge into the land of the dead or that
tracking shop through the train station
whether the lighting or the towers or
the hundreds of distinct characters each
sequence is so visually packed that
there's no way to catch all the detail
but despite their complexity they both
managed to feel absolutely natural and
that more than anything
might just be render man's most enduring
legacy are those renders still overnight
processing is how has that changed
yeah well the cool thing now is a lot of
times the kinds of images that we were
creating on the original Toy Story we
can create and almost in real time now
that's huge that's huge for artists
because when you're painting a painting
you don't kind of pretend to make
brushstrokes and then wait you know a
day for your image to come back you want
to be able to create kind of right away
in real time and we're getting to the
point where we can do that 30 years ago
render man took shape as a tool to help
artists bring their imaginations to life
by now it surpassed those aims and can
accomplish those results nearly on
demand but the most mind-blowing visual
effect means nothing if it's not in the
service of a larger goal as long as
they're impactful and they do some good
in the world
then we're doing our real job are you
still moved by these movies when you see
them yes
in fact that's what I'm looking for is
when we're going through this in the
early version sight at some point
something Wells out I already know
roughly what the the plots and the
characters are but when it starts to get
into place then I get emotional or I
laugh okay we're getting there
[Music]